foreign
promise I'm way smarter in your head
than I am in real life way way smarter
yeah that's why it usually works what's
up
um yeah so I was calling because I'm
really struggling on making a decision
about if I should stay in my marriage
um just for my son
um no you know
I don't even know what the answer is
but no
why do you want to leave your marriage
actually the way you just asked that
question why do you need to leave your
marriage
um well so we got married pretty much
just because well we definitely got
married just because I was pregnant
um he comes from a you know religious
background where it was like either you
know
um break up and not be together or get
married so we got married which you know
we were dating for a while but I don't
think I would have ever married them it
wasn't because of that
um but you did so here you are yeah yeah
you've got all this and you've got all
this background stuff that's it just is
what it is you all are here now why
isn't it not working now
well the first time it wasn't working
was just because you know we kind of
decided that we were gonna call it um
you know getting to know each other
better being married you know we were
both really unhappy he doesn't celebrate
holidays because of his religion and you
know that was very stressful but when
pandemic happened we never I never want
to like actually leaving and you know
essentially got together
and then as I was like really kind of
trying I found out that he was sleeping
with the neighbor so you know it broke
my heart and um
when I kind of I guess kind of got
opened over the brokenheartedness about
it then I was obviously like angry
and you know I asked myself the first
time we were deciding to split up like I
was okay with it I don't know if it's
because my son was more like you know a
baby couldn't even talk yet now he's
five
and I just feel like I can't picture a
single day going by where I don't wake
up and and he's there
can I just be real direct with you
Nicole of course this isn't about your
son man
I get that you you can't imagine in your
life with with like for a second I get
that too 100 like I I
um I am unnerved by how much I love
being around my kids okay almost I have
to right I I it's strange for me I get
that
but this isn't about your kid and I
don't want you to make decisions right
now with through that lens because
you're gonna end up if you leave
and some of this the the data tells me
that your net worth will go down your
life will get harder
for a season especially
that all like if you don't get I don't
want you to blame a five-year-old for
that
or if you stay I don't want him to be
the reason that you're miserable and
unhappy and that's the position you've
placed this five-year-old in
so I know you want to see him every day
you love him more than life itself all
that is incredible
you have to make an adult decision about
an adult relationship
and he can't be the glasses that you are
wearing to make that decision
I mean I've been you know thinking about
it for so long and it's just like I I
totally understand what you're saying
but like you know there's there's other
people that I see that that do this all
the time and I feel like for some reason
like I I can't like handle it like it's
it's all about my son like I I feel like
I would put up with like you know
basically like a marriage to just sorry
student language
um to just be to be you know with him
all the time like you know right listen
if you do that that's this that's an
incredibly selfish thing
because you are teaching him you're
using him as a pacifier
you're using him for you to feel better
and in the process you're like you're
using him like a blanket
and in the process you're teaching him
this is what love looks like
this is what women deserve
this is what dads do this is what
husbands do
and you're just putting cinder blocks in
his backpack that he's gonna have to
spend his whole life unwinding
yeah that was kind of what I was afraid
of it is if you don't want if your
husband cheats on you with your neighbor
and you don't want to be married to him
anymore
don't be married to him anymore
but be an adult and you make an adult
decision and live with the consequences
of that decision because you've already
made the decision to get married to the
guy
and you can't blame anybody you can't
blame his religion you can't blame you
chose that
and if you choose to stay with somebody
who cheated on you great y'all figure it
out
that happens all the time and people
rebuild their relationship completely
anew
and they come up with something that was
stronger and more magnificent I don't
want to say more magnificent like good
thing that's happened but man it
re-contextualizes what I'm worth and
what I value in the what I will and
won't put up with it just changes
everything
and you get to pick that
but you're choosing misery in a
relationship right now and I just and
you're and you're making it your
five-year-old's fault and I just don't
think that's that's fair to him
yeah
what makes you think that your husband
cheats on you what makes you think
um that you're gonna have to split
custody
um well I know that the
law in Florida is it's a 50 50
state so okay
yeah will he fight you for custody
no he won't invite me and I think he
would be pretty agreeable to being you
know 50 50. it's just that doesn't feel
good enough to me you know in a drug
world if I could just have him and go I
would have done that but I know I have
to share so have you asked your husband
that
uh yeah and he said no way
yeah of course I mean we're both super
in love with him
so what keeps you and your husband from
going away for a weekend and figuring
this thing out
I mean
um I'm not that's totally sure on that
you know I mean the the reasons why we
kind of decided to not be together in
the first place you know obviously like
all these are kind of a big deal we
don't really have the same kind of
beliefs
um
is your husband willing to lose his
marriage over these these
things like holidays and stuff
I don't know
because here's what it sounds like to me
it sounds like you got two people who
are kind of dug in
but they've been it's almost like World
War One like they're they're entrenched
in a position and the people fighting
don't even really know what we're
fighting
and you start creating stories about the
person on the other side that you're
fighting not realizing that y'all are
way more similar than you are apart
usually not always
usually in this kind of situation
one of y'all is desperate for the other
person to flip the lights on and turn
the music off and say what are we doing
because if there was no smoke left in
this relationship at all not one spark I
think he would have laughed
are you are you able to tell me this
thing is done dead and over or if he was
to sit down with you and say hey I love
you
man it's been a rocky go
we got in a rocket ship that we didn't
even know we were doing but here we are
I want to make this thing work would you
be all in or would you be like not too
bad you slept with the neighbor
um there's no judgment there's no
judgment either way yeah I'm just trying
to build a context here yeah yeah
I find myself now is like do I make that
decision to be all in or not to be all
in and you know my top of my list of my
son so you know if there's any risk of
losing him then I feel like I should say
but then if I'm only staying because of
him then you know it's a lot harder to
think of why I would say
I want you to do some soul searching
not about your son
you know where you stand there
but it feels like you got hurt bad
and you are scared to get hurt ever
again
and so you're gonna you're going to go
to the beach like wrapped up in a huge
blanket so you can get no sun on you
because one time you got burned and what
you're going to do in the process is
Miss the entire trip to the beach
you're going to miss your whole life
yeah the only way your marriage works
moving forward is if you're willing to
get hurt again
and I hate that about relationships but
it's just the truth all relationships
are a risk 100 of them
the one way you can mitigate that risk
is you take the lead and I think your
whole life you have been
just being led around by the nose Fair
yeah doing what everybody else in your
life wanted you to do
and I'd love you to take the lead and
take this guy out if if you're in and
now I'm pushing you one way
um
because that's the way I feel like we're
going on the phone I could be way out to
lunch so don't just do this because I'm
saying to okay
but I'd love to see you sit take him out
somewhere
and get a babysitter and look at him and
say
I'm not done with this thing
everything's got to change all of it
me you what I'll accept boundaries all
of it but let's put it on the table and
either we're going to both be all in or
we both got to figure out what being out
means
but this halfway thing is killing you
it's killing your husband and it's
destroying your son
yeah is that fair that
never really
actually telling him
what I want for the future if that's
even possible lay it out there lay it
out there because the worst you can say
is no and then you get your answer
yeah and then you got to grieve your
marriage and you got to figure out what
divorce looks like and all the hell that
that is
but there is a chance he says oh my God
thank God
and I want you to have written down
spent some time you may need to go see a
counselor spend some time or get with a
couple of your friends that you trust
deeply
here's what I need moving forward
and that can be everything from you
gotta get off your stupid phone to I'm
gonna have to go through a rebuilding
season
or I'm gonna learn to trust you again
because you were banging the neighbor
while I was trying to keep our house
together right I want you to lay down
all these things that you need these
things that you want
and then he's going to have his list too
and you've probably been pretty cold the
last few years Fair
oh definitely okay so let's figure out
what this thing's gonna look like lay
all these things out and say can you
live with this can I live with this
and it may be a disaster but at least
you have an answer at least you're not
living halfway one foot in one foot out
because everybody's getting hurt this
way is that fair
yes definitely will you do me a huge
favor will you let me know how that
conversation goes
and let me tell you this if you show up
to this conversation and just start
throwing grenades he's Gotta Fight You
Back
go to that conversation and say here's
what I need
and here's what I want I want to go all
in
all in or if you spend some time
thinking about this writing your needs
down a lot and you realize no I'm done
I'm done done then take him out and say
I'm done
and we need to figure out what this is
going to look like
and I'd love to see if you'll be okay
with weekends instead of weekday
whatever but we can figure something out
the it works for both of you
um
well let's stop living halfway
either go all all in
and risk getting hurt again
I'll go ahead and say it he'll hurt you
again he'll say something stupid he'll
do something dumb you'll hurt him you'll
say something stupid you'll do something
dumb
that's marriage and then it's gonna be
about are we willing to repair are we
willing to go back into the cycle again
let me know how this goes
actually have really high hopes for
y'all
this can take somebody being a grown-up
and maybe that can be you